en 1962 le livre printemps silencieux de
Richard Carson a éveillé les consciences
et fait entrer le mot écologie dans le
langage populaire déjà à l'époque
l'ouvrage dénonçait les risques associés
à l'utilisation des pesticides l'une de
nos équipes s'est rendue à Pittsburgh
lieu de naissance de Richard Carson afin
de retracer la vie et l'œuvre de cette
scientifique et auteur à succès
la prière
fin des années 40 aux États-Unis
une confiance aveugle règne dans les
technologies
protexas on asperge des enfants d'un
puissant insecticide le DDT
les pesticides de synthèse nouvelle aile
de Rado de la chimie arrivent au chant
[Musique]
la science est Dieu peu de gens osent
critiquer ces produits miracles
et pourtant
une femme tiendra tête à la puissante
industrie chimique Rachel Carson
son arme printemps silencieux un livre
choc qui dénonce l'impact des pesticides
dont le fameux DDT
et voisins étaient un avertissement
et un appel à la prudence
elle a dit nous faisons cela pour le
contrôle des insectes
pourrait être un printemps sans oiseaux
60 ans plus tard que reste-t-il de ce
livre courageux
que reste-t-il de l'héritage de Rachel
Carson l'une des auteurs les plus
influentes du dernier siècle
[Musique]
université Chattam à Pitts sur ce campus
les traces de l'élève la plus illustre à
avoir fréquenté ces lieux sont encore
bien présentes
Patricia de Marco enseigne les sciences
de l’environnement dans cet université
chaque fois qu'elle en a l'occasion elle
rappelle à ses étudiants l'immense
héritage de cette scientifique
d'avant-garde
elle a décrit le lien étroit entre la
santé de l'environnement et la santé
humaine
non seulement lancer le mouvement
environnemental
mais également celui de la protection
des espaces naturels
4 juin 1963
[Musique]
témoigne au Congrès américain
son livre vient d'être publié il force
le président Kennedy a ordonné une
enquête sur les dangers des pesticides
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
de l’industrie chimique
[Musique]
elle est gravement malade
pour moi c'est l'expression même du
courage
et elle allait le terminer coûte que
coûte
[Musique]
cette maison de springdal près de
Pittsburgh en 1907
de sa chambre la jeune personne voit
monter les colonnes de fumée qui
s'échappent des cheminées
ce sont ses premiers contacts avec la
pollution industrielle
mais dans la cour arrière la forêt et
son refuge
avait la liberté de jouer en forêt pour
développer sa curiosité et au retour sa
mère répondait à ces questions
d'enseignement
[Musique]
1925 Rachel Carson entre au collège pour
femme de la Pennsylvanie aujourd'hui
l'université de Chattam
au sous-sol de la bibliothèque on
conserve une précieuse collection de
photos ainsi qu'une quantité importante
de correspondance
[Musique]
la jeune personne est talentueuse et sa
mère veut qu'elle devienne professeur
d'anglais
[Musique]
mais les murs de scolaire vont plutôt
stimuler son intérêt pour la science
elle passe donc de l'anglais à la
biologie
ce qui marque le commencement de tout
alors affronter sa mère au premier geste
de courage selon Patricia de Marco
et l'écrit à sa mère et lui dit je
comprends maintenant ce que j'écris date
et ça c'est pour moi un tournant dans sa
vie
[Musique]
n'obtient plus tard une maîtrise en
zoologie à l'Université John Hopkins
elle entre ensuite au gouvernement
fédéral comme biologiste du milieu marin
et l'écrit sur l'importance des milieux
naturels et laisse sa marque comme
rédactrice
mais Carson veut élargir son auditoire
ce qu'elle réussit avec brio
chez elle a écrit pour le riders
entre 1940 et 1955 elle publie trois
livres sur les océans dans cette mer qui
nous entoure un livre qui restera sur la
liste des ouvrages à succès pendant plus
d'un an
mais après ce succès le ton change la
biologie c'était maintenant hauteur se
sent interpellé
[Musique]
c'est qu'au gouvernement fédéral on
étudie les conséquences des épandages de
DDT sur l'environnement
ce pesticide de synthèse est alors
utilisé dans les parcs fédéraux et les
milieux humides pour lutter contre les
insectes nuisibles et la malaria
elle voyait qu'il ne tuait pas seulement
les moustiques
elle a commencé à s'interroger
elle se doutait que ce produit n'était
pas aussi offensif qu'on prétendait
on lui rapporte par la suite quantité
d'oiseaux morts après des épandages
massifs de DDT aux champs
du public des conséquences de ces
produits
et les appeler ces choses qui tuent la
vie
à cette époque on croit les pesticides
de synthèse sécuritaire
mais Carson veut prouver le contraire
elle entreprend l'écriture de printemps
silencieux
en fouillant les études elle démontre
que certains pesticides persistent dans
l'environnement
dans son chapitre elixir de mort elle
décrit comment certains pesticides font
leur chemin jusqu'au humain
ruisselaient des champs vers les cours
d'eau et qu'ils étaient ensuite absorbés
par de petits organismes et finalement
par des humains
elle faisait des liens qui étaient
encore inconnus du grand public
dans son livre elle a donc recensé
toutes ses études et elle en a fait un
récit vulgarisé pour le grand public
printemps silencieux et finalement
publié en septembre 1962 et son succès
est immédiat
mais l'industrie attend son livre de
pied ferme
et se sont regroupés
et ils ont détruit son livre
ils ont dit si Madame Carson arrivait à
ses fins nous serions à la merci
d'insectes qui envahirait le monde
divine sexe
à cette époque on perçoit mal qu'une
femme questionne l'autorité scientifique
Carson subit les pires insultes
il interpelait
ils l'ont traité de tous les noms
[Musique]
elle n'a jamais dit que nous devrions
interdire les pesticides elle a dit
qu'il faut être prudent maintenant et ne
pas mettre ses produits entre les mains
de personnes qui ne comprennent pas les
conséquences de leur utilisation
[Musique]
Rachel Corsen décède un cancer en 1964
l'enquête ordonnée par le président
Kennedy confirmera les affirmations de
la biologie
des pesticides
au niveau campus de l'université de
Chattam on forme de futurs travailleurs
ou principe de l'agriculture durable
l'enseignement ici est inspiré par
l'héritage de Rachel Carson
tous partie de la nature
et que nous n'avons pas à la contrôler
investissement
printemps silencieux aura eu un impact
immense
il conduira la fondation de l'Agence
pour la Protection de l'Environnement
des États-Unis en 1970
à l'international le travail de l'auteur
contribuera à faire bannir le DDT dans
plusieurs pays
de son collège à Pittsburgh jusqu'au
Congrès américain
Rachel Corsen sera les au bout de ses
convictions
Patricia de Marco reste admirative de
cette femme courageuse
comment a-t-elle trouvé la force
d'écrire son œuvre alors qu'elle était
gravement malade
où a-t-elle trouvé l'audace d'affronter
une industrie aussi puissante
[Musique]
je crois que son amour pour la terre
et en particulier pour les océans
lui a fait dire ceux qui détiennent le
savoir on l'obligation de le partager
[Musique]
pour moi c'est la partie la plus
inspirante de son travail
[Musique]
l'auteur de printemps silencieux est à
l'origine de la création de plusieurs
centres de recherche un peu partout à
travers le monde les plus près de nous
elle a inspiré une scientifique qui a
décidé de consacrer sa vie à étudier les
impacts des pesticides
le travail de cette femme est une vaste
enquête
Maryse Bouchard document chaque jour
l'effet des pesticides sur la santé
humaine
en tellement
à peu près à chaque repas
il y a 60 ans la biologie se Rachel
Carson a pris dit que les pesticides
gagneraient la chaîne alimentaire
aujourd'hui
90% des gens ont des résidus de
pesticides en eux
sont des aliments les plus souvent
contaminés
la carrière de cette chercheuse a été
influencée par le courage de Rachel
Carson tout comme l'auteur à succès elle
estime que ceux qui détiennent le savoir
doivent parler pour moi c'est une
obligation je sens que c'est mon travail
de prendre parole il y a trop de
scientifiques qui hésitent à le faire
moi je considère vraiment que je dois le
faire c'est une nécessité
été 2022
Université de Montréal
Maryse Bouchard est sur le point de
démarrer une toute nouvelle étude elle
veut connaître les autres chemins
qu'empruntent les pesticides pour
contaminer l'humain on sait que
l'alimentation est une voie importante
d'exposition au pesticides mais qu'en
est-il des risques pour ceux qui vivent
en milieu agricole pour les gens qui
vivent proche des chats mais qui ne
travaillent pas en agriculture là il y a
très peu qui a été fait à tout le moins
dans le contexte canadien et québécois
c'est inouï qu'on s'intéresse pas plus à
la santé des gens qui qui vivent dans
ces zones rurales
les risques sont réels des études ont
démontré que la majeure partie de
l'ingrédient actif d'un pesticide et
dispersé par voie aérienne lors de son
application d'autres s'accumulent plutôt
dans les sols ou ruisselle vers les
cours d'eau agricoles
la vie bintique mais quand même vraiment
beaucoup de données là-dessus et
relativement peu de données sur les
populations humaines ça m'interpelle
énormément j'ai vraiment du mal à
comprendre que ce soit le cas il me
semble que c'est vraiment un angle mort
de la recherche en ce moment
l'intérêt de cette chercheuse a toujours
été tourné vers le milieu naturel
mais dès le début de ces études
universitaires elle sent le besoin de
mettre l'humain au centre de ses
recherches la lecture du livre printemps
silencieux dans un de ses cours vient
confirmer son intuition je pense que
Rachel Carlson c'était vraiment une
pionnière son analyse qui avait fait
dans son lit était très holistique
c'était pas une notion qui allait de soi
le l'idée que tout est lié que la santé
humaine est directement tributaire de la
santé des environnements
[Musique]
à l'université Berkeley Maryse Bouchard
fait ses premières enquêtes sur les
pesticides agricoles et ces résultats
font grand bruit elle Orient ses
recherches sur les femmes enceintes un
groupe particulièrement vulnérables aux
pesticides
qui arrivent à qui se passe à une
rapidité énorme et si c'est processus-là
sont perturbés par l'intervention
d'agents chimiques mais ça peut vraiment
venir faire dérailler le développement
normal du cerveau
[Musique]
elle joint une équipe qui suit des
travailleuses agricoles de la vallée de
Salinas en Californie
des femmes régulièrement exposées aux
pesticides
son groupe suivait depuis plusieurs
années le développement neurologique des
enfants de ces travailleurs
non c'est attardé au QI qui est une
mesure intéressante pour évaluer le
neurodéveloppement parce qu'elle est
très valide et ce qu'on a trouvé c'est
que plus les femmes avaient été exposées
aux pesticides de la classe des Oriano
phosphorés moins leur renfort avait un
QI élevé une fois rendu l'âge de 7 ans
donc on parle d'effet qui persistent que
plusieurs années dans le temps quand
même
la chercheuse un jusqu'ici dirigé ses
recherches sur les groupes vulnérables
comme les enfants un choix à la fois
personnel et stratégique
important pour moi c'est serait certain
il y a aussi aussi un principe de santé
publique je vous dirai si on protège le
sucre de la population on protège les
individus les plus vulnérables dans la
société du même coup on protège tout le
monde
depuis la publication de printemps
silencieux il y a 60 ans la quantité de
même que les variétés de pesticides
qu'on utilise nos cessé d'augmenter
si beaucoup restent à étudier on sait en
revanche que certains pesticides
augmentent le risque de développer la
maladie de Parkinson
certains sont également associés à des
risques accrus de cancer comme celui du
sang d'autres agissent aussi comme des
perturbateurs endocriniens et peuvent
causer des troubles de la reproduction
comme l'infertilité
si l'agriculture reste le plus grand
utilisateur de pesticides la chercheuse
refuse de blarmer les agriculteurs
beaucoup sentent que ils peuvent prendre
aucun risque
risquez leur récolte ça serait des
pertes énormes pour elle les pesticides
agricoles sont davantage l'enjeu de
toute une société je pense que c'est le
rôle des scientifiques
des universités des institutions de leur
apporter des solutions je pense pas
qu'il y a un agriculteur qui est heureux
dépendre autant de pesticides sans
compter que ça coûte très cher
pourtant les solutions existent
Maryse Bouchard Martel qu'il faut
réduire les pesticides à la source
et tout commence par leur homologation
elle estime qu'il faut davantage
d'études indépendantes avant d'autoriser
un pesticide
c'est Santé Canada qui est responsable
d'évaluer la toxicité des produits que
lui soumet à l'industrie agrochimique
Maryse Bouchard remet en question la
valeur scientifique des études déposées
par l'industrie
tous les processus de monologation se
base sur des documents qui proviennent
de l'industrie ou qui sont sponsorisés
donc sont des études textologiques qui
sont faits par des compagnies
directement payés par l'industrie il y a
un manque flagrant d'indépendance dans
ces données là
[Musique]
on sait par ailleurs il y a des
chercheurs qui sont intéressés à
comparer des études qui étaient
financées par l'industrie et des études
qui étaient financées par des fonds
publics et ces études-là ne trouvent pas
du tout les mêmes réponses lorsqu'ils
étudient la même question il y a un
grand débat lancement
c'est fondamental que le processus soit
fait avec rigueur c'est vraiment ça qui
fait qu'on a le droit de répondre
certaines de ces molécules
par ailleurs toxique dans
l'environnement
on dit que les personnes racialisées ont
des niveaux d'exposition supérieures aux
autres mais comment on explique ça par
mois Maryse Bouchard rassemble ses
étudiants autour d'un texte pour
discuter de santé environnementale
alors bien sûr l'effet chez les humains
ça va être plus grave elle amène ses
jeunes chercheurs apprendre la parole
pour elle c'est là une partie de la
solution aux problèmes des pesticides
moi ce que je vois c'est que il
s'indigne du fait que les pesticides
c'est une problématique qui va toucher
particulièrement les communautés
racisées les personnes de statut
socio-économique moins aisés qui ont pas
beaucoup de pouvoir nécessairement aussi
donc les injustices ça les touchent
beaucoup
au fond cette femme fait beaucoup plus
qu'un travail d'enquête
tout comme l'affaire Rachel Carson
avant-elle Maryse Bouchard crie
désormais des ponts entre le savoir et
le citoyen c'est essentiel les problèmes
aux
quels c'est vraiment important moi j'y
crois d'amener les données scientifiques
au public qui puisse comprendre puis
qu'ils puissent aussi faire des
pressions jouer un rôle pour que le
changement arrive